ai has cracked a key mathematical puzzle
for understanding our world
this just in from mit technology review
and
look at this puzzle right here it's got
the bumps
it's got the valleys the surfaces it's
got the braille
it's got the bits the ones and the zeros
not only going up and down like in the
matrix but going
in circles um it's got it all this
puzzle
is really hard as you can see and ai has
just
cracked it um i'm being a bit hyperbolic
of course this is actually about a new
paper
that can solve numerically solve a
particular type of partial differential
equations way faster
than anything uh before it
so this is about this this new paper
and we'll get into the paper in a second
um it's pretty cool but as you can see m
c
hammer the infamous mc hammer has
tweeted this
out and and he is actually a pretty cool
twitter feed on
where where he regularly tweets
about scientific papers and so on so
pretty cool cross-domain overlap
i recommend that um so we'll get into
the paper we'll get into
the code a little bit as well because i
think it helps to understand
what's going on and i want to start out
by this is the the blog post uh by one
of the authors
and it's it's pretty good to get a basic
overview of the paper
and here is the motivational example
so the motivational example is the
navier-stokes equation
which is an equation in fluid dynamics
so
you're trying to predict how a fluid
evolves over time
given a certain parameters like its
viscosity and a forcing function so
basically how sticky it is
and how hard you stir it and
then you want to know how it evolves
over time
and you can see on the left is given an
initial condition and i think on the
right
is sort of a rollout after the
10th time step until the 50th time step
and the ground truth is obtained with a
sort of classic numerical solver where
you do
little time steps and you calculate the
interactions and then
this takes a lot of time and compute
and on the right is the prediction of
this new
fourier neural operator that this paper
develops
and you can see it's almost equal and
the gist of it
is that the thing on the right simply
takes
one forward propagation through a neural
network so it takes
like super like point zero zero
something
of a second to compute the thing on the
right whereas the thing on the left
is quite hard to compute and as i
understand can take
minutes so use here you see the the
motivational example these things are
described by partial differential
equations which
are sort of linearized um linearized
ways of describing how the system
evolves
over one time step and it'd be cool if
we could solve this faster because this
is applications in
aerodynamics and other types of
engineering
fields all right so let's jump into
the paper and as always if you like
content like this consider
sharing it out telling your friends
about it and
subscribing of course so the paper is
called fourier neural operator
for parametric partial differential
equations
and it's by tsungi lee nikola kovacky
kamyar aziza denesheli borigiri liu
kaushik patacharya andrew steward and
anima anan kumar
of caltech and purdue university
so um i feel i feel the
the paper is both very cool
and a bit overhyped um so we're going to
see what it does it's it's for a
particular type
of pdes and it has a lot of
let's say engineering choices that make
it possible to solve with neural
networks
but also that limit its applicability
to where the classical methods um
would be applicable where this thing
isn't so there are trade-offs
uh definitely to reach the sort of speed
up that they reach
but we'll we'll get into this first i
actually want to scroll down
right here all the way because um there
is something that you don't
often see in the sort of machine
learning
field and that is here in the
acknowledgements
section and i just you know i just find
this i just find it interesting don't
don't don't regard this as anyone but
here we are um supported by
the um lwl grants which i understand
is darpa beyond limits which is like a
makes soft or makes a.i or systems for
things like gas and oil and so on with
british petroleum
as a main sponsor raytheon which of
course is a giant military
manufacturer we have the army
research laboratory and so on so
um so you can see that this
this is uh kind of
i don't know i i don't see this often
this is sort of
uh a good bouquet of sponsorships of
course there's also microsoft google and
so on um
yeah but it's just it's just interesting
to see that
that the the army is pretty heavily into
these things and of course they would be
i mean
rockets need to fly and they need to be
aerodynamic and so on so
um yeah i'm not saying this is bad or
good i just thought it was
it was interesting that you know
raytheon
uh would would be a sponsor of this
all right so let's dive in as we said
um we're interested in these types of
of problems right here where you have
this thing
called so the there is this quantity
called the vorticity
which as i understand is a a derivation
of the
viscosity um so it sort of tells you how
the
fluid is is moving uh right now
and so this this state right here and
then you apply a
a sort of constant forcing function and
you want to know
how that evolves over time so you can
see at time step 15
you get sort of this picture so these
these move past each other
you see this moves here this moves here
and then at time step 20 you can see
they are
fairly moved okay this blue thing moves
in here as well
and they just sort of mix and
there's this uh there are certain
parameters that make the fluid more
sticky or not so sticky
and the interesting regimes is i guess
when it's
not very sticky but so not not too
sticky but also not
not sticky enough and then these really
complicated
uh patterns occur and to predict them
would be
very very valuable so you want something
that takes in
this initial state right here and
outputs
all of these these future states and
usually this is done by these classical
numerical
solvers so the navier-stokes equation is
described by
a set of partial differential equations
and you can see this down here
so navier stokes
equation is described by this
set of equations right here is there
yep and you can see that the
um that this this
is fairly complex it includes partial
derivatives gradients and so on so this
is the
this is this vorticity and um
it includes that on on both sides and
this
is this the yeah this is two derivatives
maybe or is it just the delta i don't
even know
i'm i'm not an expert in uh partial
differential equations
by any means so anything coming from
that direction
don't take me for granted i'm going to
give you sort of the
unders the thing of what i understand
from this paper
and so with respect to that entire area
i'm not an expert i i just can
understand that this is
fairly complex and what you usually do
is
you take the initial state and um
you just evolve it in time so you you
take this time parameter
and you do you go one little little time
step
and then you calculate because these are
all sort of linear
linear equations you calculate this one
little time step into the future
you update your state right it's it's
sort of like
you you know your points here and how
they move
and how they move is given by their
gradients
so these are all sort of linearized
things
now you don't want to move them too much
per time step
because ultimately if this thing moves
and this thing moves then the movement
of this arrow will change because this
thing over here moves right
so you want to compute this one little
time step
into the future like to here and this to
here and then you want to recompute
all of these arrows so maybe now that
points a little bit more
here and that points a little bit more
here and then you want to update it
again so
you have these sort of these these
numerical solvers that
go little tiny time step by little tiny
time step it's not even
this if here if you see t equals 20 or
something it's not 20 time step for
these solvers but these usually go
like a thousand or a hundred steps per
time step that is here
or something like this they need to take
very tiny steps to be accurate
and that takes a long time so the idea
is
can't we simply can't we simply simply
input
this let's say this thing or or like
something at time
15 and directly predict
the thing at time 30 and that's exactly
what this paper does and a lot of papers
have done
this before but without much success
so this paper proposes to do this in the
fourier domain and we'll see the path
that they take right there so
they go into uh the we'll shortly
go into sort of the the basics right
here
so what you want what you're looking for
is
a function g that takes
an a and gives a u so what are a and u
a and u are both function spaces so a
a and u here are functions
so a is a function as you can see a is a
function
and u is a function but you can
characterize them as
data points so in this in this way there
is a
functions and data points are sort of
interchangeable
you can see an image like this
as a data point where it's an image
but you can also see it as a function
where
every x and y coordinate is
mapped to a value right so when when
they talk about functions
um very often they talk about this type
of function
where you have x y and t so t is also t
is zero here
x so the function would x y t
map that to some value right we hear
um the vorticity and you want to
transform
this function so this function would be
a
a would be the function at time let's
say
0 or something or times 0 to 15
you would want to map that to the
function
the function u that also takes an x and
the y
let's leave t out for the moment it also
takes an x and a y and
let's say t but t is set to 30
and maps that to a verticity right
so you want to input a function and
output a function but it's
the same as inputting an image and
outputting
an image in as for from an engineering
perspective of course
uh from a math perspective it's a little
bit
different but other than that
it's a fairly standard machine learning
problem
so you have this these sets a and u
and you're looking uh for this function
g that maps a
to u okay so
we study maps which webs g which arise
as the solution operators of parametric
pdes suppose we have observations
where a is an iid sequence from
probability measure
mu supported on i and u
is the a transported by g it is possibly
corrupted with noise we aim to build an
approximation of g
by constructing a parametric map um
this g right here so it's a bit of a
mathy way of saying
we have a bunch of data points where we
where a
this is the initial state goes to u
which is the state at some point in time
and we know that there is a function g
this is this g
with this inverse cross we know that
there is a
true function that maps any a to u
so a single function g that
can if i input the initial state can
give me the output state
and what i want to do is i want to
approximate this by a
parametric version so these here are the
parameters
and of course as you can guess by now g
is going to be
this g right here is going to be a
neural network
that is parameterized by theta so these
would be the layers of the neural
network
and we're going to input a into the
neural network and we're going to get
out
u so that's
basically that there is uh quite a bit
of
math right here and the math here is to
derive what they call a
neural operator so here is one layer of
this neural network
as we said we're going to input a
now a first thing that we do
a is going to be let's say up
projected so a is going to be made into
a latent representation v0
so this is let's call that
here p so there is a
function p which is going to be a little
layer of neural network
and it is going to produce this v0 so v0
is going to be a
latent state of the neural network
and then there is going to be a number
of these layers
that transform this to v1 v2
v3 and
we've i think there are four layers of
these
in their particular implementation but
there don't need to be four layers you
can choose that
as you can choose any depth of neural
network and then at the end
you're going to project that down to
whatever
output you want so u okay so this
function here is called q
and these are just going to be neural
networks so p
and q are going to be your very very
classic
up projections and down projections of
data point we'll get into
actually we'll get into um sampling
let's go actually right now so so
one thing right here and they stress
this is that they work in function space
right they
they don't they don't work on the let's
say they don't map the data point to the
data point
what you could do is simply have like a
convolutional neural network an image to
image network
and so on but what is the problem with
that
so if you have your a which is your
initial state
and um it has you know it has this bunch
of fluid things right here
and what you do when you have an image
is you sample this right
you sample this a different sorry
maybe a regular grit i am terrible at
regular so you sample this into a
certain amount of pixels
and your neural network will operate on
this right this will give you some kind
of a tensor
which is um let's say we have a
so this is a seven by seven grid okay
so your neural network is going to
expect this as an input dimension
and whatever u is of course so you map
this to
u which is also going to be some sort of
image
okay where you need to output pixels
so again you have some set resolution
and your neural network can only operate
at that particular
resolution what they're doing right here
is the cool thing about is it can
operate at any resolution so once you've
learned the network you can input
higher resolution images or you can
output higher resolution images any
any sort of um you can deal with
more resolution less resolution sampled
irregularly
you can deal with a lot of things once
the neural network
their neural network is learned and how
do they do it
they do it by um only
ever acting pointwise in the spatial
domain
so what they're going to do is they're
going to
take this a and now we get into
the more critical things so here a and u
aren't just the beginning state and the
end state in fact in this navier-stokes
example
a is a tensor like this
so a is going to be a tensor with slices
and each slice describes one time step
up to a given time so this here could be
t equals zero so there is kind of
the initial distribution and then t
equals one and so on up until t
equals uh like 10
let's say i think they do 10. so
it they let this thing evolve for 10
time steps and i'm going to guess they
do it
using one of these classical methods and
that's the input so the input isn't just
the initial state the input is actually
here is what happened in the first time
10 time steps and then the output
isn't just at the output at some
particular time
but the output is actually also
a slice right here
um sorry a sliced
tensor so each slice here describes
the output at a particular time so
this would be t equals 11
up until t equals 50.
okay so this is this is you
so the top one is sort of the conceptual
thing
but the bottom one is what really
happens so they input 10 time steps and
they get out
the 40 subsequent time steps they
predict them all
at once okay so and now
you can see that in this particular case
how i can understand this is
at each pixel here
i want to know what what is that pixel's
value after one after like
a certain amount of time steps okay like
or 50 right here or 40. um
and of course the result
is going to not only depend on the time
0 but on the entire evolution of time
0 to time 10. so this here is an
entire column for that pixel and
this is akin to that particular pixel
having this many channels so here i can
just say
well these are technically 10 channels
or
11 or something like this i probably
screwed up this should be t equals 0 to
and then 10 to 49 but um
so this is this is an entire stack
this is we can interpret this as input
channels
right here and we can interpret these as
output channels okay so ultimately
one pixel is going to have input
channels um
all the time steps that happened up
until the point
where we want to predict and the output
channels are going to be
at the same time all the time steps of
what we want to predict okay so
these projections now coming back to
this
they simply work in the channels so
these p
and q they are one by
one convolutions and the one by one
convolution simply
up project and down project
these features you see these are
one by one convolutions actually they
could be dense layers let's check that
in the code later
but for sure what they do is they
only work point wise so they don't
they don't mix the individual pixels
together
in here you simply get at like a
d by d grid with each has 10 channels
and then you simply up project that to
so here you have
d by d times 10 and then you up project
that using p
to d by d times and here
is a parameter that you choose so this
is sort of your latent dimension
okay and you are going to transform
this tensor keeping it in this d
by d by w dimensionality
until you back project it using q
to d by d by
in this case 40. okay
so but this this and this they only work
point wise
and that means there is no particular
dependence on the
d right here so the next data point
could actually have a different d
as long as this pipeline right here can
handle
different dimensions because the p and q
only act point wise
you're good so what do what do these
magic layers here do so these are these
fourier neural operators okay
they transform one hidden state into the
next
note that we have four of these layers
so they don't need to be
the same as the number of time steps
we're trying to predict
you see and it's pretty clear from here
so um we these four hidden layers
they're simply
transforming this entire
volume right here this entire input
volume
they are transforming this and as a
sequence of latent states
and then outputting this entire volume
so this
down here has nothing to do with the
time
steps that we're trying to predict it is
simply
a sequence of computations of latent
computations and you know
that in a neural network the deeper you
make it the sort of
more complicated functions arise even
though of course the universal
approximation theorem says that with one
hidden layer
you can do anything but in general if
you have deeper neural networks
uh the more mo you can kind of
make more complicated things and uh
so four seems to be a good number of
complicated for these particular
problems
so here's what one of these layers does
it is very much like a residual network
so
here you have v d
v as the hidden representation
at t plus one and t plus one
is not as i said is not the time step in
the sim in the uh navier stokes
sense of time evolution of the pde this
is simply the layer
t plus one so i don't know why they
maybe yeah maybe t here
makes still makes sense is it not
because
it's large t
yeah so they have large t right here
okay maybe but in the engineering sense
it is not it's simply the
layer and you can see it's formulated as
a function
but again don't be like the x right here
this is simply the x and y and t
uh coordinates so this this all of this
here
can be represented as one big tensor x
y t or x y channels or something like
this
okay don't so don't
don't be confused by the fact that these
are formulated as functions
so what we want to do is we have two
different things
so one neuron this is one neural network
layer as you can see at the very end is
a non-linearity
this is a pointwise non-linearity and
this is
in the original pixel space or in the
original
spatial space the d by d space each of
the
things gets a non-linear function
slapped on top
as is normal then this part is normal as
well
this is simply a linear transformation
of the input again this is pointwise
okay so this is a linear transformation
so so far so good we have
a linear transformation of the input and
a non-linearity
the important part is this thing here so
what this thing is this is a kernel
function that depends on the initial
condition so not only on the last hidden
state but the initial condition
and sort of is then uh multiplied
by the last hidden representation
like like here and then
only x is applied so notice the
difference right here
this is at a point x we're getting this
function value which means we're getting
the entry of that tensor
and then we're applying the linear
transformation okay
this makes it pointwise
here first we compute this function
by this by applying this kernel to the
input function
so to the entire input tensor and only
then
we are looking for the particular entry
so that means this thing here
is a pointwise transformation of that
tensor while this thing here
it takes in the whole tensor and outputs
a
sort of new tensor
so this is going to be the the magic um
here where k it goes you can see it goes
from from a u space to u space
uh maps to bounded linear operators on u
and is parameterized by theta
maybe what's this i don't know i never
know
so the this this kernel we choose this
to be a kernel
integral transformation parameterized by
a neural network
so they define the kernel integral
operator as this
and you can see this is an integral
over the uh d d is the input space
of u and a actually so
this is a function that's dependent not
only on where you are in the tensor
but on the initial uh input this a
and then that's convolved so this here
is a
a integral over the entire space
so that's convolved with v you can see
that this is a convolution
and it's fairly complicated so this
alone tells you
nothing but luckily
they say that they restrict this
so it's a bit annoying when things
always depend on this a
and that means that each of these
functions right here each of these
arrows right here these are the neural
operators actually let's go here
each of these fourier neural operators
right here
they would always also depend on
this a here like this
and like this and like this
this is a bit annoying for deep learning
because we sort of want
one layer's representation to go into
the next one so they simply make an
engineering choice and say
uh nope nope nope so
so they say
we impose right we impose
if we remove the dependence on the
function a we impose
that the kernel is simply a function
of x not only x and w
but only x minus w
so now you have a a sort of proper
kernel function
in there that we can handle
we obtain that 4 is a convolution
operator okay it wasn't a convolution
before it was just an integral
but now if you restrict your kernel
functions to this
you get a convolution we exploit the
fact
in the following section by
parameterizing k directly in fourier
space and using the fast fourier
transform to efficiently compute four
this leads to fast architecture which
obtains state-of-the-art results for pde
problems
so there's quite a bit of math right
here
to finally arrive at this thing
here so what is all this math for
this math is for saying what we want
we want to build our neural network like
this
okay and
what we do is we simplify
and specify this kernel thing until
the kernel looks something like this
so we restrict the kernel to be a
convolution and
since a convolution in fourier space
is just a multiplication what we can do
is instead of taking the function v
and convolving it with this kernel what
we can do is we take the fourier
transform
of the function v then multiply it
in fourier space by this thing and this
thing is now
simply a matrix that's learned
in as as a bunch of parameters and then
we do the inverse fourier transform
now you might ask why is this relevant
why can't we just um why can't we just
do
a convolution like we do normally and
the reason is so when you do a fourier
transform what do you do
you have a some kind of signal
like
and so on you have a signal and you
transform this
into fourier space and here we just go
like
one vector so here as you know in
fourier space
you have these basis functions which are
sort of these different parameterization
of sine waves
or you can do it with cosine waves and
they get
faster and faster and so on so you know
that you can
decompose any signal into
its basis functions in this kind of
periodic function space
so this function right here it might
have you know 1
times this function plus
0.1 times this function plus
2 times this function minus 5 times this
function
and so on so you can describe any any of
that
now for these type of pdes that we're
looking for
the special thing about them is they are
fairly well described if you simply
cut away the sort of top fourier
modes and only work with these because
they are
you know sort of the the individual tiny
ripples
you might not want to take into account
so you can truncate the lower fourier
modes
and that's what they do exactly here
and they learn
so instead of transforming this signal
directly
into the next hidden representation uh
they go to fourier space cut the top
fourier modes
they they have a way of
making the next representation in
fourier space and this is this r
here and that is simply a weight matrix
that they multiply with
and that is you can you can prove that
that is the same
as convolving in or
in the original space so multiplying in
fourier space is the same as convolving
in the original space and
so they multiply the green numbers right
here
by r then you get something out so
i should maybe this is way too much so
the green numbers you multiply by
r to obtain new green numbers
so maybe r is the is 2
2 4 so the new green numbers would be 2
0.4 then you
do the inverse fourier transform
so you get back to a signal now with two
times this so it
might be bigger and .4 times
so i can't even draw but you you sort of
get the idea
you put it into fourier space um you
apply
the function r which is a multiplying by
a matrix that you learn
in fourier space uh you get new fourier
coefficients you map them back
and there you have your next layers
representation
almost okay so this is this fourier
neural operator and it's described
right here what you do is you
take your representation your hidden
representation
you put it through a fourier transform
which you can do in a differentiable
fashion
you get these fourier modes
um which describes how to decompose the
signal
into these periodic functions
you throw away the top modes which is
your sort of
regularization you apply
r which is in a dense layer of neural
net not even that it's it's a
multiplication okay
by a weight matrix um
and then you obtain this these new
fourier modes you do the inverse
and then you have the next
representation almost what you do is
we saw this before a pointwise
transformation
in the original pixel space
so this is very much like a residual
network right a residual networks they
also have this
they have the implemented as one by one
convolutions
um so and then at the end you apply
the non-linearity what is good about
this
two things first of all throwing away
the top fourier modes
is very advantageous to these types of
problems that we have right here
you can see that the little the little
jiggles right here
they will be sort of sorted out by
the larger scale movements of the fluid
so throwing away the top modes is
a sort of a regularization it helps with
generalization
and it's very easy in fourier space so
these things
other than natural images are described
well by these fourier spaces and that
again is an engineering choice so you
cannot not apply these things
to everything you can apply them to
where this
type of assumption holds second of all
this is now fully independent of the
discretization
of the input okay because
when i take a picture and i sample it in
a three by three gate
i can do a fourier transform and i'll
get
all of these numbers right here okay
it's just uh you know the fourier
transform does a good job as possible
when i sample it in a seven by seven
grid
like i sample it super densely i do the
same for transform i get the same
numbers
right here okay and it's not exactly the
same so they always claim
it's the same it's not exactly the same
of course if you don't sample
densely enough your fourier transform
isn't going to be
as accurate let's say so ideally you
want the fourier transform of the
real signal of the real underlying
signal
but since you sample this you can't have
this
so there is a bit of a difference but it
is
independent so that's true so the
function r that you learn
simply operates on these fourier modes
and these are fairly independent of how
regularly you sample
of course more regular better but still
fairly independent um
yeah so so that's that's good so
if you if you have what they're going to
do is they're going to
have something like the 3x3 during
training and then sample more densely
during
during inference which is something you
can do but understand that this is just
it's just a form of interpolation right
uh so the inverse fourier transform
simply
uh gives you whatever you want
interpolating using the fourier
modes it has and of course given
a certain number of fourier modes which
is quite small for them
i think it's something like 8 or 12
higher resolution at some point doesn't
help you anymore
because you've cut off the high
resolution fourier modes i guess what
can help you is this
this thing right here but this thing
right here only acts point wise
so you see this is now fully independent
of the discretization of the signal
which is a cool thing so the two cool
things about
this entire stuff is that first of all
independent of discretization second of
all
these types of problems that we are
having here lend themselves very well to
be described in fourier space
um yeah so that's why i'm saying this is
for a particular type of problem
and also there are a bunch of other
things you can see right here
you have this entire input tensor right
here and this entire output tensor
right here and these can be fairly large
right and all the intermediate
representations have to be
kind of at d by d by w
um so this is
you can't go infinite time right here
like you could
with a classic solver like a numerical
solver
all you need is the last time step right
you go what's that
t equals 1 then at t equals 1.1 1.2 and
so on
you just count up and you just go always
from the last time step to the next time
step
here since it's a neural network
during training you need to keep all of
these
tensors the intermediate things i guess
you can do gradient checkpointing but
this
is engineering-wise you predict all the
future time steps
at the same time so you can't really go
infinite in time and
how do you train this thing um
you train it by simply giving it one of
these a
right you have a you have a bunch of a's
so you have a bunch of these
input tensors a data set
and where you always say here is a one
of these
navier stokes equation sorry
type of problems i've sampled it somehow
and i've let it run for 10 time steps
and then
i've let it run for longer you
so i let it run for longer and here are
time steps so this t equals 0 to t
equals
9 or 10 let's go 10.
and here is t equals 11 to t
equals 50. okay so you have a data set
and this data set is fully computed by
a classic forward solver so you can't
replace the forward solvers right yet
because you need them
for generating training data right so
this becomes
your training data this becomes
generally your x and this becomes your y
and now you're learning this neural
network this entire thing to
give you x to y so you see you still
need the classic
solvers to produce the training data
that's the first thing
the second thing is you can pretty
clearly see that
um the good thing is
that now we can input any a so the
classic solvers you need to rerun them
for each initial condition
now we simply train with a bunch of
initial conditions train the neural
network to predict what happens then
and then it can generalize to other
initial conditions but you know about
generalization that
the problem is we can
we can only trust our neural network if
the problem we're considering is very
similar
to what we had in the data set it
doesn't arbitrarily generalize
okay so that is you know
it it's something to remember so i said
all of these things have trade-offs
trade-off one there is you have to
predict all time steps at the same time
which is hard on your memory right it
limits the size of things you can do
trade-off two you can only
really trust the neural network if the
problem you're considering is within
your data set vicinity
there are other problems that we've
mentioned problem three we've made
very specific choices with respect to
how our kernel looks that it's only ever
dependent on
x minus y so therefore it is a
convolution
um there there's all these these
channels
you know engineering choice more you cut
off the top fourier
modes which um limits the types of
signals you can analyze uh the next
choice is the
number of intermediate computation steps
right here
which limits the complexity you can
assume
and so on so there are just i'm not
saying you don't have choices in the
other numerical solvers you probably do
but um just
remember there that that this is the
case
so someone might say well can't you
can't you just
if you want to predict for longer time
steps you could make this t
equals 11 and then simply you know not
not go in slices of one but maybe going
slices of a hundred so this could be t
equals 111 this could be t equals
211 and so on
and that is completely completely valid
um what they actually do is they
subdivide the space
further so instead of doing like 40 time
steps they are doing
like 80 time steps but still times 11
to 50. i i believe um
the the problem with extrapolating like
like this and leaving away time steps is
that see here you have a supervision
signal in your training
for each of the times and
it it might be that the fact that so you
know
time step 15 looks something like this
and i know i'm trimmed to mness time
step
16 is just like a small evolution
like this from right it's it's like a
small
difference and it could be that the
neural networks
because they don't have internal
dynamics right they don't internally
like
dynamically simulate this physical
system they simply learn to map
things to things and if if they are
still
related to each other a lot then
sort of they can make sense of it so if
one slice so this could be the slice 15
and this could be
slice 16 if if these are sort of related
you know it it can it can it can make
sense there is a relation between them
also you can implement this as an rnn
and then also from one step to the next
it sort of
makes sense you don't need an internal
dynamic simulation however
if you jump from time step 15 directly
to time step
115 right then
it might look like it might look nothing
like it right
because it has evolved so much and there
can be
quite chaotic dynamics and that's the
entire problem with pde is that the
dynamics can be super complicated
and not easily predictable so here you
don't really have a relation
right and so since the neural network
doesn't do internal dynamic simulation
it probably wouldn't i'm going to guess
something like this
wouldn't work too well i could be wrong
but i'm going to guess uh classical
solvers are still needed for this type
of situation so that's the
other limiting factor is that you sort
of
are are bound to data samples
that can be statistically correlatively
predicted from one another
without having to do um
these physical the real physical
underlying simulations
though i've been proven wrong in the
past
all right so they talk a bit about how
the fast
uh fourier transform plays into this and
there is actually an interesting thing
which we'll see
at the code and then they have three
examples um like the darcy flow
burgers equation and navia stokes
equation
and they also do these base and inverse
problems
where i i believe the um
[Music]
what here what you have is sort of a
thing at
time step you have the bottom thing
given at some time step and then you
want to find out
the original thing and what you do is
you have like an algorithm
that is simply guessing so you have a u
given and you want to find out the a
so the a is unknown so you simply start
with a zero
and guess what u is going to be from
that a zero so you evolve
your state a to u and then if it's not
entirely correct
you try again you try a1 okay what does
that give me now
you um so you see you kind of play a
game of guessing and you have an
algorithm that does this guessing
kind of smartly so it says ah now that's
not the direction i want to go to it's
sort of a reinforcement learning
algorithm a little bit
and the important part is it needs to do
a lot of these forward evaluation right
it needs to change a a little bit
and then evaluate and see if the u that
comes out is the same as the
u that you want so you want to find the
initial state of any given
evolved state and if you need a lot of
forward evaluations
it's going to be a problem if the if the
forward evaluation is really slow like
these classical simulators so these
neural
networks can really help right here and
i think they bring it down
they bring down the time it takes from
18 hours or so to two and a half
minutes for this entire evaluation
so that's pretty cool and they also
outperform actually in terms of error
they outperform uh these these kind of
baseline methods
so this is pretty cool as well so not
only are they faster they
also are less error prone
all of this is pretty cool now let's
just spend like a short time
to dive into the code the code is still
quite a bit quite hacky but that's
research
so deal with it so here you can see
that the the top class is what is called
this
net 2d so
net2d i i always i like to look at the
forward pass
uh before i look at the how the network
is made
uh because you understand how things
flow so in the forward pass you simply
have this
conv this this convolution right here
what's called conv1 it's not really a
convolution right
this is this um this is simply an
instance of this simple block and x is
just passed
through it so this simple block
right here by the way the data
is prepared as you can see there is
quite a bit of
preparation going on so you have
a and you have u so a
as you can see is prepared
as an s by s that's the discretization
of the grid
uh by t in so this is your d by d by
10 like this is ten input time steps
and it is already expanded to
a t tensor so the t
is going to be the output steps that
we're going to consider
so here a is going to be transformed
repeatedly into a
a tensor that ultimately will have t
output time steps you can see you have
to hold one of these
things in memory for each training
sample
and then you annotate actually x and y
and t these are like positional
encodings uh for if you know transformer
positional encodings these are simply
linear
position encodings for x y and t
you concatenate those and off you go
so
where were we x was forward passed
through this simple block 2d
what's the simple block 2d the simple
block 2d
is this thing right here so again let's
look at the forward pass
so first of all we're going to fc0 which
what looks like a fully connected
layer we're going to permute the axis
then we're going to
through conv0 w0
a batch norm and
a relu so you can see this
right here is what we saw in the diagram
x1 and x2 are the different paths
through the network this is the top
path if i go back to the paper quickly
this is the top path in this diagram
okay and the bottom path
is this thing right here
and then there the two are added and
then there's a batch norm which is not
in the diagram
and then there is a relu okay so the
bottom path is pretty simple and you can
see right here
by the way they restructure it
that this is going to be pointwise so
this is not going to be in pixel space
this is going to be a
point wise only in the channel
the transformation so these w's are
implemented as
one one by one convolution you see it's
a
1d convolution and the kernel size is
one
so all these does is for each point
for each point in the grid space in the
pixel space for each pixel
we're going to take this all of this
pixels channels
and transform this into a new vector of
the same amount of channels
so you can see the input channels and
output channels are always the same
dimensions so
actually this entire network right here
operates on this
width which is this latent dimension
it's only the first
layer that transforms this from 13 which
is 10 plus the three positional
encodings
to this latent dimension and then the
last
network this transforms it from the
hidden dimension to 128 for some reason
and then 128 to
1 which is each pixel has a
one-dimensional output which is this
vorticity
that you're trying to predict um
and by pixel here i mean an xyt
entry okay all right so
um yeah so
exactly so this goes from 13
to 1 and then it is reshaped again of
course to the
uh to the appropriate size to give you
all of the outputs
okay so you can see this is the input
this is the
output down here in between we have
four blocks of this um upper path and
lower path
so the upper path sorry the lower path
we just saw is a one by one convolution
and the upper path is this conv0 so this
con
0 is this spectral con 3d fast
okay and it's parameterized by these
modes so the modes is how many of these
fourier modes you want to retain we
we saw we throw away the top fourier
modes whatever they are
and the modes here is whatever you want
to retain in this case is set to
uh four which is actually eight if you
work it out and we'll see
why so this spectral con 3d fast again
let's look at the forward pass so what
does the forward pass do it does
a fourier transform a fast fourier
transform
and at the end it does an inverse
fourier transform
okay so this is certainly certainly
we are now in the top spar part right
here
fourier transform and at the end inverse
fourier transform
and now this r in the middle is
implemented a bit
weirdly because of how the fast fourier
transform
works what you get basically
you get an image out of it um not you
got actually a 3d thing but
you get an image and the important
fourier modes are not like
at the bottom or at the top the
important fourier modes are actually
in the corners right here so what you
what you want to cut away is all of this
all of this middle part if you want to
throw away so this is equivalent
to uh throwing away these high frequency
things right here so that's why this is
implemented
so weirdly um you can see
that here uh first we are going
up to the modes in each of the x y
and t direction but then
we're also going from um
here we're going to the last modes in
this direction with all the others
this is corner this is corner one this
is corner two this is corner three and
this is corner
uh four sorry the the bottom two right
here is corner four
uh it's a bit weird and we don't have to
actually do this with eight
corners which you might have guessed
because
why don't we do it with modes three you
see modes one and two they always appear
negative and positive
and you would guess we need to do the
same thing again with negative modes
three
but we don't because this thing here is
one-sided which um because this is
con con because this is um
a has a property of of um conjugacy
uh a lot of these entries of the fourier
transform would actually be
sort of symmetric and the one-sided
only gives you one part of these
symmetries such that it doesn't waste
memory and it does so for the last
dimension
so this dimension right here doesn't
have this corner
properly it's a bit weird and you need
to know the exact implementation of the
fourier transforms but you know that's
what it is
um so you can see that
this mole 3d here
is a it's complement 3d it simply
multiplies the
input which is the signal right here
by these weights the weights as you can
see
is simply a weight matrix
that is in channels out channels modes
modes modes and
two two because it's complex numbers and
you see
in this multiplication um that
the this is a complex number
multiplication so the real parts
and the real part is this the imaginary
part is this
and the operator is an einsum operator i
just thought this was funny
it says mixes yoxes
boxes just as i challenge everyone to
make einstein einstein some
notation that spell cool words bixis
yoxy's boxes
um but the the important part here is
so a is going to be the signal which is
going to be a batch
in channel and then x y t uh
b is going to be the weight that comes
in the weight matrix which is in channel
out channels x y
t and you can see pretty clearly in the
einstein notation
also here that the input
channels are multiplied away so these
are summed over
and what results is the output
channels so this is basically a matrix
multiplication
for each of the samples in the batch and
for each
location xyz it's a multiplication
summing over the input channels
resulting in the output channels
this is pretty standard pretty standard
transform
mapping vectors to vectors
it's complex it's in fourier space but
ultimately it's just a multiplication
so this is the code they simply do four
of these layers um going to fourier
space and then back again
two fourier space and then back again
why do they do this
because as we saw they throw away these
higher modes right here
and that also limits severely
this applicability so if you only throw
away the higher modes if you just do
everything in fourier space
you severely limit yourself in fact
these fourier methods they
are already not really good for
problems that have like non-periodic
boundary conditions
so the the periodic boundary conditions
um
case is as i understand one of the
easiest cases
and so the the applicability would be
limited and the authors
hope that by sort of doing this in the
real space
all the time and also having these
encoder and decoder networks
that they can retain uh sort of this
informations
and and and be applicable to more than
just
periodic boundary conditions
um yeah exactly
and and that's basically it um
i was ranting for so long i think
we are through to this paper so maybe a
quick summary because this was a bit
bit of a rant right so you want to
predict these types of things
these types of things are well described
by by their
fourier analysis so transformations in
the fourier domain
actually make more sense because the
evolutions of these thing is more or
less kind of these
uh global signals it's not localized
like natural images like there's the cat
and there's something
these this this pattern right here it
will
repeat you know as you go into infinity
these these sort of patterns will repeat
and repeat so
the sort of global interactions between
these
periodic signals is much more important
that's why it makes sense
to go to fourier space to transform that
in fourier space you can regularize by
throwing away
the higher modes and you get the
additional benefit that you are
discretization
independent so you learn the function
once and then
you can input differently discretized
signals as you choose and the function
stays the same because the fourier
transform it will
do as well as it can with the
discretization that you give it
once you're in for ea space you simply
have a multiplication
and it's actually interesting the
filters here
the author shows some of the filters
that are learned so
on top you see filters in a cnn and
on the bottom you see these filters
these fourier filters learn these are
actually
as i understand these are transported
back to the
pixel space so we can understand them so
you can see that the global kinds of
patterns that these
fourier operators are sensitive to
compared to the cnn filters which just
have like localize a certain pattern
so this is this is quite interesting
so it makes sense to go into fourier
space there are a number of trade-offs
you have to do
you um specifically you have memory
requirements
and you can only predict signals that
are similar to what you've seen
in the training data set um
and you could only solve things with
periodic boundary conditions
but by means of architecture of these
encoder and decoder networks at the
beginning like the p and the q
and the fact that you always carry
through and a residual way
the uh pixel space signal makes it
such that you might get around this you
might
right it's not it's not a proof but
there is a possibility that you might
get around this in total
this thing is way faster and more
accurate than uh baselines
and has applicabilities and is sponsored
by
the uh nice people at the military
all right so this was long i realized
but i invite you to check it out the
paper is technical
but well written if you stick this kind
of
math part out in the middle
it's pretty cool all right check out the
code and
i wish you a good time bye-bye